στην αστυνομία να καλαγκελθούν να γίνει έρευνα στην κεφαλη αγοράνοι όπου δήποτε αλλού πρέπει να
γίνει τουτντο πράγμα αλλά οι εννίκεσι δεμια αυτόν είναι μια ιδέα μα γενικότερι ιδα τη
οποία εγώ θεωρό ότι αν δημοκρατικώστεις εναγερμός πρέπει νασε πέπει ένα σευόμαστε τον επιχρηματικόν κόσμο
πρέασεευγώ μαστε τους άνθρώπος πουουλεύκου και περιχχαίνυν επιτυχίες το εξωρικόν χτίζουν επιχειρήσεις ποτομιδ εργοδωτούν κόσμο
παρέχουν τες δυνατόητες που βλέπουμε δι ότι ότι για να γάμει το κράτος θέλεικαι ν
αγοράν οι οποία να παρέχει το βιωτικών επίπεδον ενώς λαού εκαι παρέχειτη το κράτος καικκαιχιμοντέλνον
ιστόπιτο κράτς αναλιώνιεκατάλιπρέ βρέβα ξ σητο λθαράκε και ν το λιθαράκελ λιγό δεν πούμε στουνταις
επιχειρήσεις που είνεται αν υπάρχουν κακή σε όποια δήποτε τομέας υπάρχουν ε σσόποιο δίποτε τομένόμως
εν πορεί να ο μαδοποιούμε όλο των τομέα μια ιδέα ότι λ και τούτον το
πράμ το βλέπου εντα τελευταία δεκά χρόνια στην κύπρον να να γίνεται ότι όλοι είναι
κλέφταση όλοι είναι δευθαρμένοι όλοι έχουν αυτό το πράγμα δεν μπορεί ο δημοκρατώς θαιμο δεν
έχει ποριοδημότο κάος να το ιοθετήσει αυτόαυτή εντιριτορικί αυτό τελος πάντ δεν μπορώ εγώ να
την ιοθετήσωα στωπούμε να τσ αυτή διαφορά σε μια ιδέα νομος έι είται διαφορά παράοικακά
όμως υπάρχουν θέλωματο κλείσω έτσι μπορεί να δίνεται ια λά θασμένοι εντίπωση πολλές φορές στον
κόσμο ότι διαφωνίες που μπορεί να έχουμε οι οποίες να σε επίπεδον ιδέας ότι είναι
προσωπικές διότι όλοι είμαστεν υποψιασμένοι ότι κάποιος κάτι θέλει